K-pop singer and actor Lee Jihan has
died he was among the victims of the
horrific crowd surge tragedy in Seoul
South Korea over the weekend he was just
24 years old it started out a
celebration thousands of mostly young
people finally freed from coveted
restrictions crowded into a narrow
Street in downtown Seoul Lee Jihan was
one of 154 people killed in the incident
which occurred on Saturday in it Taiwan
a busy nightlife District in the capital
city thousands gathered for Halloween
festivities however the crowd size
became overwhelming leading to panic and
an eventual fatal crowd surge by the
time rescue workers arrived 10 minutes
after the first SOS call they had
trouble pulling people from what had in
seconds become a lethal crush the actors
talent agency 935 entertainment released
a statement to multiple Outlets
confirming his death which reads in part
quote we would like to express our
deepest condolences to his family who
are patent by the sudden tragic news
also to everyone who loved him
Lee Jihan first gained Fame competing on
the second season of South Korean
reality singing competition series
produce 101 where 101 contestants Vie
for a chance to join an 11-member K-Pop
group
[Music]
after appearing on the show Lee Jihan
began acting in 2019 and quickly booked
a role on a popular Korean drama series
foreign
[Music]